I mean this is just a conversation
between me and Rick but if anyone else
is eavesdropping on this conversation
like you should seriously try ice cream
if you haven't tried it yeah if you
haven't tried ice cream you got to give
it a shot it's I mean what are you
waiting around for it's not gonna one
cup of ice cream isn't gonna kill you
yeah it's I mean let's be real you're
not gonna die from one cup I mean you
know unless you're unless you're lactose
intolerant oh yeah of course you've got
a there's always one of those in the
crowd man I want to try ice cream I
heard it's pretty good
it is pretty good Morty it's pretty good
it's ice cream
you gotta get you gotta get that
delicious taste of ice cream and the
delicious taste of ice cream that'd be a
good slogan for the ice cream
corporation I'm already the ice cream
corporation let me tell you that they
are in need of slogans you should have
heard their last slogan what was it it
was ice cream come and taste it slips
down your throat oh that's kind of I
don't know it's not that's not too bad a
slogan Rick well maybe it's not so bad
you're right it's not too bad I got it I
got a good slogan for them ice cream get
your ice cream here step right up
huh that's a pretty good slogan it's got
a nice Bell to it it's got a nice ring
to it I meant hey Rick um we should
start an ice cream company that's a good
idea Morty I'd be honored to start an
ice cream company with you Morty yeah
Rick I'd started ice cream company with
you he's the old son of a [ __ ] shut
your mouth Morty you little piece of F
ha ha ha you little piece of s we're
gonna start an ice cream corporation
Morty we're gonna take over the entire
ice cream corporations of all of them
man we're gonna take over a whole ice
cream corporation calm freakin or ice
cream Morty
we're gonna make so much ice cream we're
gonna drown the whole world in ice cream
I'm gonna take a big ice cream all over
somebody's face whoa Morty
whoa that's not cool I don't know what
you're implying with that phrase the way
you phrased that I don't know I just I
meant like you know you put ice cream in
your mouth mount your mouths on your
face
I figured that was kind of you know okay
okay I'm sorry
say no more I apologize huh
brick who Morty it's a nice day out
there there's five of them and I've had
five forties
oh that's cannon alert memory collection
what did you do it's not useful to me
alive it's better this way you kept the
chip inside him this whole time
yeah Morty I hide all my secrets in
Morty's you should know that by now
you're like a walking safe what the [ __ ]
what what are you even talking about
Rick I can't begin to comprehend how
stuff you need to be in the brain to
even begin to allow this to happen
maybe you eat chicken Morty what do you
think happens to them you know it's a
cold universe factory farming Morty you
know if you if you if you want to sit
here and preach you might want to
consider putting your money where your
mouth is going vegan or or whatever and
leave me out of it it's not my problem
if you really tore me apart with that
Rick you know you're right I'm going
vegan this is canon morty is now vegan
this is canon canon I'm Vee I'm a
full-on vegan now season for all vegan
season for 100% vegan Morty Hertz shut
up forty
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have brand new Rick and Morty to break
down before season four starts were
almost there this is a bonus episode
that was done between seasons with some
bonus content in a collab between t-ara
y and justin roiland they recorded some
new dialogue for the episode but as you
probably spotted there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs I'm actually working on a
new collab with tiara why for Rick and
Morty season four right now as we speak
and there's a special collab that I'm
working on for special merch for Rick
and Morty season four that I'll explain
at the end of the video I'll be doing
Easter egg videos for all the episodes
this season just like previous years so
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I do merch giveaways every week too so
like I said this is meant to be an
expansion on a bit that goes all the way
back to season two from the butthole ice
cream shop from interdimensional cable
to Justin roiland was actually teasing
interdimensional cable 3 earlier this
year in the sound booth while they were
recording voice over for season 4
episodes and if you listen to the
commentary for season 3 episode 8
Morty's Mind blowers they actually tell
a story about how they originally plan
to do interdimensional cable 3 during
season 3 but it was when season 3 was
originally supposed to be 14 episodes
instead of 10 they had an unspecified
production issue that prevented them
from doing the extra four episodes so
they canned interdimensional cable 3 for
a future season and just did the episode
as Morty's mind blowers but big surprise
it turned out great so now I'm hoping
that they actually do more teas mind
blowers too in a future season so the
bit is just meant to be a
tongue-in-cheek fake pitch for them to
actually go to this ice cream shop
surprisingly are not surprisingly
there's no Szechuan flavored ice cream
either you also probably notice the doc
and Marty graffiti that's actually the
original project that Justin roiland
created based on Back to the Future that
wound up turning into the Rick and Morty
cartoon when it went to Adult Swim
there's a bill cipher of gravity falls
symbol some meeseeks they're having that
awkward kind of conversation you have
someone when you don't have anything to
say and you're just riffing off of each
other's comments Rick even censors
himself within the episode like he stops
in himself from cursing instead of them
bleeping it these dogs aren't based on
the lawnmower dog episode from season 1
episode 2 through actually based on
Justin roiland original dogs from a dog
world series that he was doing a long
time ago boy
I thought our lives would be relatively
unaffected by taking and talking humans
but they behave so differently
here's t-ara wise icons signature strike
lock is one of the VFX people that
worked on this another big gravity falls
easter egg Stanford Pines in another
version of Rick playing with his portal
gun I will do a really big gravity falls
Easter Egg video from all the Rick and
Morty episodes at some point because
without fail within a couple separate
episodes almost every single season they
have some sort of gravity falls Easter
Egg hidden in the background lawyer
Morty not a real lawyer
talking to judge Morty based on the
state of Georgia versus Rick Allen if
you haven't seen that animation tiara
why also animated a version of that but
it's the most insane real-life court
case that Justin roiland recorded voice
over for is if it were a Rick and Morty
case it's him reading the transcript
from a real-life insane court case it's
the most ridiculous thing you'll see
your entire life in it's almost two NSFW
for me to include in this video that's
how hardcore it is you're gonna tell me
[ __ ] listen shut up listen to me there's
a pineapple Express logo from Futurama
there's the characters from Olin Rogers
final space cartoon the red balloon is a
reference to Jerry's game I think that
Adult Swim even turned that into an
actual mobile game for a little while or
at least a flash-based game when it
glitches out like they're inside the M
night Shyamalan episode that's from the
Rick and Morty VR game there are five of
them in the I've had five Morty's lul
that's cannon joke is just a reference
to our Morty not being Rick's original
Morty I know there are a lot of theories
about evil Morty being Rick's original
Morty I don't think they're gonna answer
that definitively anytime soon during
season four but they did say that it
would be important that you re watch
season three so that you understand some
of the plot lines happening during
season four just implying that they're
continuing evil Morty's story as we all
expect it in some of the other more
serialized elements there's a couple of
fourth wall breaks when Rick says it's
canon and Morty speaks about himself in
third person on his desk here you can
see he's got a new pickle experiment
running with pieces of robot Morty all
over the garage the chip that Rick pulls
out of robot Morty is from the pocket
Morty's game the face on robot Morty
also kind of reminds me of the robot
Morty from the old intro
as well as Season three Episode two Rick
dancing the stone when Rick had the fake
morty in summer to mislead Beth so she
wouldn't know that they were gone
toes my thread in the morning he just
became my backup toaster lot of people
wondering about the last part where
morty says that he's going vegan vegan
for season four that's canon that's just
a joke from the vr game
I don't expect morty to show up vegan in
season four or anything like that
dan harmon and justin run also make
jokes about including stuff in the canon
to like where they're playing with mr.
poopy butthole and his promo here
structural problems for a particular
obstacle on this episode no problem mr.
Penhall mr. poopy butthole adult musics
that's canon morty floating here in the
vacuum of space is just a reference to
the campaign manager morty from the end
of season 3 episode 7 and then there's a
clip with a phone call from summer
trying to yell at him for being bad
about his phone skills and texting so
it's an awesome collab I hope we see
more bonus content like this in the
future just because it's really cool
especially between seasons when there's
such a Content drought but the big idea
was season 4 and their restructure deal
with Adult Swim and Turner is that they
can deliver as many episodes as they
want I know there's a ton of questions
about why they're saying there's only
five episodes coming during season four
in the first big trailer that they
release but that's just for the first
half of the season before the big
holiday break so if it wasn't clear
there will be five more episodes after
that they haven't said exactly when
that's going to premiere but I'm
assuming for now unless we hear
otherwise it's gonna be really early
next year in January sometime they did
the exact same thing when they premiered
season one where they aired half the
season went on break for the holidays
then came back with more episodes in
January so don't freak out too much now
I'll be doing merch giveaways and all my
Rick and Morty videos all you have to do
to enter those just be a subscriber and
leave your best Rick & Morty season 4
Theory on the video there is a special
merch collab that I'm working on with
Adult Swim but that hasn't quite been
locked down yet I'll explain it in a
future Rick and Morty video if that
actually winds up happening
congratulations David crooks you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Rick &
Morty giveaway please email me on the
about page of my channel so
can get your details while you wait for
everything click here for all my Rick
and Morty season 4 trailer Easter eggs
and click here for all my other Rick and
Morty season 4 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]